all right firefighters in Southern
California are battling two new
wildfires that broke out this morning a
wildfire in San Bernardino is growing
fast and threatening buildings and a
fast-moving fire in Riverside County has
already burned at least two homes these
are live pictures crews faced a major
battle yesterday in Simi Valley
northwest of Los Angeles the flames came
dangerously close to the rung Reagan
Presidential Library and two nearby
neighborhoods about 30 thousand people
were forced to evacuate Carter Evans is
in Moorpark California Carter what do
you see there
well good morning this pink fire
retardant that you see here is really a
big line of defense for these homes
there are still more than a thousand
firefighters working this fire and these
high winds that are expected to continue
until this evening flames raged into the
night fueled by wind gusts up to 70
miles per hour this fire in Simi Valley
ignited just before dawn Wednesday
coming within feet of the Reagan Library
which houses memorabilia including Air
Force One this fire is raging right now
you can see the vortex of flames and
smoke and wind blowing in our direction
just imagine what it's like for
firefighters to approach flames like
that the fire quickly consumed this barn
where volunteers help rescue animals
trapped inside one horse even seemed to
turn back to lead other horses to safety
despite an all-out assault flames still
managed to jump a freeway forcing a
nearby neighborhood to evacuate
we put everything in the car and I'm so
glad we did because by the time it
jumped at 23 freeway we only had seconds
to get off to battle numerous fires
throughout the day emergency personnel
had to evacuate some patients on
stretchers the winds were powerful
enough to knock over big rigs along this
interstate yet vigilant firefighters
kept spot fires from exploding while we
were talking to captain Anthony Romero a
spot fire popped up right next to a fire
engine
dick ative of this fires behavior huh a
bunny on a head well just like that so
what you got to maintain for us is just
constant awareness that the fires gonna
keep moving if we want to maintain our
vigilance just because it is an active
firefighter now the cause of this fire
has not yet been determined but Southern
California Edison a utility did say that
it started near one of their power lines
and it had not cut power at the time the
fire started Gail
all right thank you very much Carter
Evans